everyone loves the gray - JD knee and
now ladies and gentlemen the seer of the
unseen the predictor of possible futures
wearer
of a stupid costume a floating head that
somehow still has a fat ass now ladies
and gentlemen the great Jay Dini those
who have never heard the great Jay Dini
you will get a glimpse into the future
of our world what will happen yes it's
2019 oh but we wanted to know what will
happen the years ahead
oh great one Oh Krusty sheet clairvoyant
please in your infinite wisdom tell us
what our futures will be what great
things will happen my mumbling mystic
and please say them as articulately and
clearly as humanly possible I know it's
difficult oh great why yes oh hey JD I'm
a floating head with cheeto dust in my
head
I speak an ancient mumbly language
called hanging in hotel register you'll
be quiet and let me get through this Oh
giggly mumbly crystal gazer you who
wears glasses but sees way into the
future you who says hmm
like almost a grunting animal oh my
Mushmouth Merlyn it is time jdd o great
one the medium who wears an extra-large
are you ready to speak yes are you ready
for my first prediction I really am
I predict Rani the limo drivers fiancee
will burst into tears at her wedding
what she realizes Rani lived through the
entire ceremony o great one o my pudgy
prophet o my smelly shaman what is your
next prediction I predict the LGBTQIA
pee will start calling themselves the
drama club to save time
a real Nostradamus predictor of things
that will come what else will our future
hold please oh great Jay Dini
I predict that instead of finding coal
this year naughty kids open their
stockings to find jet season tickets it
was all right in other words what you
were saying is the kids are gonna find
instead of coal in their stocking Jessie
when he said nutty cake all right oh my
reader of tea leaves and waster of
income enlighten us O great one Oh what
is your next prediction
I predict an earthquake will strike
Mexico that is so powerful the country
splits open and candy falls out like a
pinata
oh great bomber of comedy
there isn't a joke that I can't kill all
my king of crusted sheets
oh my obese observer of all things
president past and future Oh guru who
eats stovetop stuffing oh great great
Jay Dini who mumbles under means great
fire of jokes what is your next
prediction another surgical change and
becomes a clock radio beep alarm clock
there you go there you go oh great one
oh yes oh great one who keeps his
crystal ball under his crusty feet and
only pulls it out for important
occasions yes Jay Dini share your wisdom
Oh pathetic psychic Janani go ahead
during the first year of his second term
yes second term Donald Trump will
replace Obamacare invade Iran and build
a 2,000 mile wall all with their sharpie
you don't like we need to do sharpie on
the math thing Oh peanut butter prophet
okey who explains every job trying to
somehow salvage it the great Jay Dini
oh great Jay Dini your next prediction
please
I predict Lenny Dykstra will transition
to a woman purely to eat his own vagina
all right Oh [ __ ] of the astral plane
what else do you see
I predict Oprah Oprah will unveil a new
line of healthy snacks
beer-battered butter crusted deep-fried
cheese drenched beef nachos with
cauliflower mmm that sounds good JD
hungry yes dee dee JD or JD me JD hey
Danny who bombs with everything be right
back
he who has no comedic timing whatsoever
oh the great one all-seeing overeater
JD knee shitty add liver JD knee the
possessor of a third eye an eater of a
fourth meal it is he Jane grace is our
studio JD need please your name JD JD
knees in a green-screen outfit which
means it's a tight green leotard white
so on the end you could see his head
floating I say [ __ ] the effect just show
me the possessor of all wisdom I have
the body of a green bean bag neo black
hole of entertainment please bestow us
with your paranormal abilities and
abnormally large man titties JD what is
your next prediction
I predict louis c.k returns the TV in
his new show comedians at cars jerking
off in front of other comedians in cars
I see you can do it oh great one
oh my white ass predictor JD knee you
have done it the louis c.k one got a bit
of a laugh yes
J Dini buffoon of bombs molester of
jokes magnificent muffin top has only
two more jokes Robin predictions maker
Jill
I predict yes JD and JD puppet will
switch places without telling anyone and
Fred will stick his hand up JD's ass Oh
Algie butcher of words with your large
belly and small savings we can tell us
the final prediction prediction
I predict Sirius XM will keep expanding
until it becomes serious Pandora Heinz
Cheetos Papa John's Burger King squatty
potty massingill xn there you go creator
of bun subscribers I don't see any more
predictions he who is comedy kryptonite
you have filled us with knowledge please
close your psychic portal to the unknown
and take off that stupid turban never
show your face again for two more years
pleasure your life
J Dini puppet you should go hide your
head in shame you did nothing all time
mark you could have made it funny old
gray one I predicted my bank account
will always look like a bowling score in
2020 I will take my entire family to a
baseball game and be stuck with the bit
whoops Oh Jay Dini puppet you who just
saved the day
J Dini how does one thank you for your
presence here today knowing what a
psychic told your psychic abilities
takes on you oh and my Long Island
extra-large do you predict in two years
when we have you back that you will
somehow have learned how to deliver your
lines better that you will somehow
listen to this performance go over it
and figure out a way to be funnier
predict answer is No
oh my micro Dosher with a macro
waistline UJ Dini
aware of the largest green-screen suit
ever in the history of shows I predict
this green suit is cutting off all blood
flow to my brain right now oh great
tubby telepath and have spoken in it see
you in two years
JD with that we leave the great ones say
your catchphrase as you leave mekka
lekka hi mekka hiney ho or whatever
alright thank you
[Laughter]